langage choque des savoirs et des
formules vraiment et je pense que
d'ailleurs à l'éducation nationale il
faut éviter cela parce que l'éducation
nationale c'est le temps long et
personne ne peut penser que un plan
construit de cette manière-là va régler
ce qui pour le coup et la réalité du
système scolaire français le choc des
inégalités qui frappe fracture
aujourd'hui l'éducation nationale
l'école et depuis longtemps et les
responsabilités sont sont partagés donc
c'est la première remarque que je
voulais faire c'est difficile de se
pencher comme ça en quelques minutes sur
le le le le programme de de Gabriel Atal
mais ce que je comprends euh de ce qu'il
va faire euh mes frères euh déterminer
et décider que dès la 6e on va faire des
groupes de niveaux en mathématiques et
en français c'est décréter dès la 6e
qu'il va y avoir les élèves à la cave
les élèves au rez-de-chaussée et les
élèves au premier étage et et c'est
s'assurer dans ces cas-là que ceux qui
vont être désignés pour aller à la cave
dès la 6e ils resteront jusqu'au bout et
on sait parfaitement et et les sciences
éducatives l'ont montré les sciences
sociales également qu'à partir du moment
où on crée des groupes de niveau de
cette manière là très tôt pour le groupe
qui se situe en bas de la hiérarchie
pour celui-là dans un système qui est
déjà ultra élitiste pour celui-là les
inégalités s'aggraveront et ce que je
crains et ce que je vois d'ailleurs à
travers ce ce ce programme c'est la
réalisation du d'un fantasme des milieux
les plus aisés aujourd'hui et je crois
que c'est difficile d'échapper à son
milieu et et l'intérêt de la poli
Gabriel c'est justement de s'arracher
aux représentations aux imaginaires du
milieu auquel on appartient d'un mot
justement et cet imaginaire des des des
groupes les plus aisés en France c'est
de penser que ce sont les élèves les
plus en difficulté les élèves issus des
milieux populaires qui tire tout le
monde vers le bas et on se retrouve avec
une proposition qui va finalement
réaliser ce fantasme des des des milieux
les plus aisés j'ajoute milieux les plus
aisés qui scolarisent la plupart du
temps leurs enfants dans le secteur
privé dans le secteur public et et et et
je je crois que tourne le dos à la
mission fondamentale de l'école toute
une partie des classes moyennes qui
envoi leur le pardon leurs enfants vers
le privé est-ce que la vraie inégalité
elle est pas
là une fuite des des élèves de classe
moyenne vers le privé et qui le public
est-ce que c'est pas une réponse aux
parents justement peut-être alors la
question c'est est-ce que élèves oui
mais c'est pas pareil est-ce qu'on fait
quand on est ministre de déducation on
est là pour rassurer les parents dans le
but d'obtenir leur voix 3 ans plus tard
ou est-ce qu'on obtenir que leurs
enfants reviennent vers le public ouais
j'ai pas l'impression que j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit la pente du du
du ministre de l'Éducation je pense que
si l'enjeu c'était lutter contre les
inégalités la question de la mixité
sociale dans les écoles privées devrait
être posée la question qui est là aussi
l'enquête PISA elle est très
intéressante sur un point elle dit quoi
et c'est c'est les proviseurs qui la
renseignent dit que les élèves
interroger dans l'quête PISA C de cette
cororte là dans 67 % de leurs
établissements il manquait des
professeurs pour assurer un enseignement
correct il n'était que 18 % des
proviseurs à le dire en 2018 ça veut
donc dire que les conditions
d'enseignement se sont globalement
dégradées que les classes sont
surchargées et qu'on on répond à cela en
disant quoi et bien on va acter le fait
que le système éducatif français qui est
très inégalitaire très élitiste va
fracturer
finalement une des générations dès
l'entrée en 6e en groupe de niveau mais
alors lui il dit déjà un qu'on peut
sortir de ces groupes de niveau qu'on
peut évoluer dans l'année d'un groupe à
un autre en fonction de ses compétences
et que deux les élèves qui sont dans les
groupes les plus des élèves en
difficulté il y aura des créations de
postes pour qu'ils ne soit pas plus
d'une quinzaine par groupe puisse pour
faciliter leur apprentissage est que
c'est pas
le la mission de l'école c'est élever et
émancip élever et émancip là on va dire
dès la 6e notamment dans les milieux les
plus défavorisés vous êtes en bas et
s'il voulait permettre la circulation
d'un groupe à un autre il créerait ce
qu'on appelle des groupes temporaires
selon les besoins c'est pas nous selon
les matières mais selon les besoins
flexible avec des circulations pourquoi
pas il favoriserait le travail en groupe
ce qu'on fait encore mal aujourd'hui à
l'école et au collège mais là dans les
faits on va mais concrètement donner à
avir une segmentation de la société à
l'intérieur d'une même classe en groupe
de niveau et avec une hiérarchie sociale
qui est déjà quasi immuable où les fils
d'employés deviennent ont employé
eux-mêmes les filles de cadre viendront
cadre elles-mêmes c'est cette repru plus
l'école aujourd'hui c'est plus c'est
plus un ascenseur social aujourd'hui r
mais mais il y a
indiscutablement une promesse qui est
celle de l'école qu'elle ne tient pas en
matière de lutte contre les inégalités
c'est c'est l'échec de de de de de notre
école depuis maintenant plusieurs années
sinon décennies et et sur laquelle tout
le monde se
penche le fait est que j'ai le sentiment
que Gabriel Attal prend
qu'il faut un système élitiste il ne
lutte pas contre cela
mais